anyway here with reaction let's give a
nice welcome she's the author of the
upcoming book Serenity in the storm
[Applause]
Travis welcome up here
all right it's a simple philosophy
everything's free and we're gonna you
know how to really disarm in terms of
the economy and energy production and
will enrich China along the way how does
it make sense you know Joe Biden said I
oppose the green New Deal he said over
and over again well he's essentially
backroading back during the green New
Deal through these new EV standards
which we know 75 of lithium is in China
so let's get China Rich let's cut our
CO2 emissions Hemorrhage jobs and all of
our emission Cuts be wiped Away by a day
or two in China in what they emit it
makes a whole lot of sense that's common
sense you pay 15 to 20 grand more they
pillage Mother Earth with big machinery
to get the Cobalt and the manganese and
the nickel to build the batteries uh you
know Clay I'm looking at all this does
anybody here prefer an EV I don't care
if you do and is there any one person
oh not one person here yeah and you know
this because we do radio the EV they're
trying to wipe out AM radio so you can't
even listen to your show your show my
show all of us right right uh but you
you mentioned that 93 trillion you know
when we started the Tea Party we were at
10 trillion dollars in debt we've added
22 trillion dollars in debt in the last
12 plus years
93 trillion dollars more even little
things like Russia you know we're trying
to prevent them from being able to sell
their oil have you seen the data they're
actually selling it to Middle Eastern
countries and they're using it and now
they're working their way around all of
this all of it is much less clean than
the oil and gas that we produce and so
it's infuriating to see the cost that is
coming out 70 of people think the
economy is awful under Joe Biden and
they're right it is I mean do you guys
feel comfortable with the economy right
now I mean it's ridiculous all right let
me ask this question
if we produced all of our energy yes and
we were energy independent again uh is
that good for foreign policy do you
think a national security okay do you
think it's good for high paying career
jobs right okay do you think it's good
for our allies in Western Europe you
think it's good for them okay give me
one reason we shouldn't be producing it
because it is the lifeblood of the
world's economy you're exactly right I
mean look I I heard one person put it
this way earlier in the week do we want
to energy independent to focus on an
energy source where we are abundant in
this United States we can drill for it
we have it here at home or be dependent
on China for Rare Earth minerals in
order to produce our energy I think the
answer is obvious but we have a
president he said this the single
existential threat to the world is
climate change this is where this guy's
heads at I could think of a few others
like you won't Harden I think I know
where it says literally vulnerable China
Russia Saudi Arabia you know these are
new alliances it's a huge we're making
them our most hated uh adversaries
wealthier right look at what they are
able to do because we're not producing
our own oil and gas it's not just that
we're diminishing our economic output
output we're Rising them up it's crazy
and it's infuriating and there's no way
to defend it I just wish once all of the
people that are advocating for the green
New Deal I wish they would give up
flying private right just if you care so
much
about the future of this country maybe
flying commercial for the rest of your
life instead of flying all over the
place on your privacy well that's right
you can do that I love Davos every year
you get 1100 private jets flying in to
talk about climate change and lecture us
about eating meat that's my favorite
that's right yes we they've never heard
of Zoom all right so how do we stop this
the only way I see to stop it is to win
the next election yeah yes no doubt
about it you must win we must have a
president who a nominee I should say who
goes into this clear ride as to who
they're up against uh who delivers a
choice to contrasting agendas get rid of
the personal attacks here's my plan
here's how Joe Joe Biden's ruining you
because the unpopular personal polling
of Joe Biden doesn't translate to
electoral Victory unless we deliver the
American people a Clear Choice what do
you think I I think Haley's 100 right
about that I also think you have to call
out some of this craziness when they say
oh we're gonna just do away with oil and
gas in the next decade I mean Joe Biden
is dementia riddled in my opinion I
don't think he really understands what
he's saying but there are a lot of True
Believers he seems brilliant
you know he almost spelled eight
correctly you know he only left one
letter off uh yesterday
um but you know there's so much out
there of True Believers that they
legitimately think that by 2033 there's
not going to be oil and gas powered
vehicles I think they're all a little
bit they've lost their minds I would
also just say really quickly Joe Biden
hit in the basement last time we tried
to smoke him out of the basement tough
to do we got to smoke them out of the
oval because he's going to try to hide
there that's a great line
how great is Kaylee in play great job
thank you both appreciate it hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else